Forgetting ... forgetting is a good thing.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann, and
today I wanna talk about vocabulary
and the importance of forgetting.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell to get notified
when there's a new video.
And if you're on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I really do appreciate it.
So when I wrote I should...
yeah, when I wrote my book, here
is of course the English version.
Here's...
I just happen to have the
Chinese version nearby.
A Personal Guide to Language Learning.
The linguist, I called it.
Linguist means someone who, you
know, speaks many languages.
That's the original meaning
of the word linguist.
Whenever I say that, I get attacked
by people who study linguistics.
But if you open up a dictionary
that in fact is the number one
meaning of the word linguist.
Most English speakers are not
familiar with the word polyglot.
Anyway, when I wrote that book, I
said the most important, sort of,
measure of how well we know a language
is the number of words we know.
Vocabulary is key.
Words and phrases, but phrases consist
of words, so you have to have words.
And to be fluent, you actually
need a lot of words because the
native speaker has a lot of words.
So if you're exposing yourself to a
native speaker, speakers in conversation
or watching a movie or listening to a
podcast, all of which are tremendous ways
of improving in the language, you need
a lot of words, and while I sometimes
hear people say, Well, I can be fluent
with 500 words, because 500 words
accounts for 60% of most content, but
in fact that's not true because the low
frequency words and frequency declines
very quickly, as I've said before.
They're key to, you know, the
gist of what any content is about.
The high frequency
words are not a problem.
They repeat often and very quickly get to
know them, but you need these other words.
You need a high sort of vocabulary level.
So, how do we achieve that?
I think one of the things that
can help us is if we accept the
fact that we're gonna forget.
Not only accept the fact that we're gonna
forget, but realize that forgetting is
a key part of the strategy of learning.
And, and there are a number of references
and I did a bit of Googling, so.
You know, I, I, I Googled
Proust, Marcel Proust, the, the
French, uh, you know, novelist.
And he has this term ... the
creative effect of forgetting.
And sometimes those things that
we don't deliberately try to
remember, they kind of stay there.
That was his intuition.
Now if you wanna see a more scientific,
sort of, explanation of that concept,
I uh, uh, recommend that you Google
for Robert Bjork uh, B J O R K and
the word forgetting, and you'll see a
number of of videos that he has done,
which explains why forgetting is such
an important part of learning that
in our memory we have the ability to
retrieve something, but we also have
this issue of what we have in storage.
Okay.
And to some extent, if we try to train
the ability to retrieve a limited set
of information, words, for example, we
aren't building up that storage, larger
storage of material that we may not be
able to retrieve right now, but it's there
potentially available for us to retrieve.
And he explains very clearly that once
we forget something and we retrieve
it again and maybe we re-forget it
again and we retrieve it again, we're
expanding that sort of reserve of
things that we can uh, uh, retrieve.
We are developing a large vocabulary
and to do well in languages,
we need a large vocabulary.
Even if our large passive vocabulary
is not available to us to use or
gradually becomes available for us to
use it is enabling us to understand,
to understand, you know, interesting
conversations or interesting sources
of, of information in the language.
So I think sometimes in schools we
are trained to not wanna forget.
We're trained, you know, the
teacher teaches something and
we've now gotta try to remember it.
Or we have tests on what was said
in the story and we're very much
oriented towards trying to get
it right, trying to retrieve it.
And I sometimes think we would be better
advised to accept that we're gonna forget.
And accept that the process of forgetting
is, is building up this reserve
that our ability to retrieve that
information is, is going to improve.
But in the meantime, we also
have to build up that reserve of
words that we will eventually be
able to access better and better.
Robert Bjork also, uh, has
videos on interleaving.
Pointing out again how important it
is to to learn things in different
environments and at different
times and in different ways.
Read about the same subject
matter in different books.
I've called this grazing in the past.
Not worrying too much about
what we retain, but making sure
that we expose ourselves to this
information in different ways.
He says, for example, people are
sometimes advised to always learn
something in the same place.
So if you study, study in your library
or study in your, I don't know, kitchen
or whatever, and if you study there and
there is research to show that if people,
you know, having studied something, if
they go back to the place where they
studied it, they'll remember it better.
However, you're better off to not
do that, to study it here and then
somewhere else and somewhere else.
So your ability, ability to retrieve
the information if you go to a
different setting may be less.
However, by studying that same material
in different environments, even you are
building up your reserve of information.
And that will eventually
give you more information.
Even though in the short run your ability
to retrieve the information is reduced.
A good example of learning things in
different environments, learning and
forgetting, building up our reserve
is the way I use LingQ on my iPad.
Could be on your iPhone or
Android as well, or on the web.
So if I look at our mini stories, for
example, lesson 59, I can read it in
the full lesson mode or I can go, you
know, uh, so here, for example, here's
page, the next page, but I can also
look at it one sentence at a time.
So that's a different experience,
varying the experience.
The way we do things is
a good thing to do here.
For example, I have a number of
words that I am trying to learn.
I, I don't spend a lot of time
deliberately trying to remember
these words, but I can still go
through some of the, you know,
exercises here right after the page.
So I might ... is accessible I hope.
...
okay ... and I don't try too
hard to remember these things.
I just kind of go through them.
... in other words, being no,
being as seeing how...
so I get it wrong.
It doesn't matter if I get it wrong.
Continue, and then in what you will
soon be seeing is the opportunity then
to, to reassemble this into a sentence.
I do it not for all the text,
but I do it to some extent.
But the key thing is I don't worry
about what I don't understand.
I don't worry about what I forget.
I vary how I do things.
Sometimes I do it in full text mode.
Sometimes I do, you know,
a sentence at a time.
Sometimes I do easy content,
such as the mini stories.
Sometimes I do more difficult content.
I never worry about what I
forget because I know that
forgetting is the key to learning.
So I just wanted to mention that
because a lot of people seem to get
frustrated when they forget things.
Forgetting is not a bad thing.
Forgetting ... forgetting is a good thing.
You wanna forget and relearn
and hear it in another context
and read it in another context.
Trust the fact that eventually the
vocabulary will stick, but expose yourself
to a variety of contexts and don't just
try to learn one, sort of, limited group
of vocabulary items in one specific
way, but rather build up your vocabulary
reserve becasue you're gonna need it.
So increase your vocabulary by forgetting.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.